i want to start today with something
i've mentioned before but i think it's
um really time to have a more detailed
conversation about and this is what i'm
calling
and some others are calling coronavirus
vaccine
alarmism which really has to stop now i
want to be really clear
coronavirus vaccine alarmism
i'm not talking about anti-vaxx people
here
i'm not talking about people who say the
vaccine is unsafe
or that it's microchipped or that bill
gates has some nefarious role to play or
that it's a population control device or
that
it modifies your dna that's anti-vaxx
what i'm talking about here
is what i guess makes sense to call
vaccine alarmism which is people who
are fine with vaccines as far as we know
but the sort of disproportionate focus
on
the vaccines aren't 100 effective
we don't know if anything can change
when you are vaccinated and other types
of
talking points that are inadvertently
maybe
reducing interest in the vaccine and by
so doing
are actually going to have the effect of
extending the pandemic the new york
times
had a great article about this called
vaccine alarmism
by david leonhardt looking at the costs
of vaccine
alarmism and in the article david points
out that
there are hot takes and opinion pieces
being widely published right now that
start with something like
listen the coronavirus vaccine is not
100 effective
if you are vaccinated you might still be
able to transmit the disease to other
people
the variants might make the vaccines
irrelevant
and no one's behavior can change
even when vaccinated for a really long
time without making it clear what needs
to change for people's behavior to be
able to change
and when you kind of take it all
together it starts to sound like
well the pandemic will never end and the
vaccine change is nothing for me
so why even go through the hassle of
looking for an appointment
and getting a vaccine especially if it's
not 100 effective
and you can still transmit the disease
and you can't change your behavior
in any way for the foreseeable future
now if you break down it actually
functions much like a conspiracy theory
you hear it all together and it's like
wow yeah that that that's a lot
but if you break down each piece into
its
component parts you find that while
there is
some truth to each individual claim
there is so much missing context and you
end up with a completely distorted view
about vaccines let's actually do it and
break it down
for example the vaccine is not 100
effective
okay yeah that's true but with the
pfizer and moderna vaccines
at 92 to 95 effective these
are some of the most effective vaccines
in the history of vaccination and
importantly not only are they 92 to 95
effective they are almost 100 effective
at preventing
serious covet and so uh when you
start hearing well it's not a hundred
percent effective i don't know
that is extraordinarily misleading and
it is a
huge huge huge additional amount of
information you need
beyond they're not 100 effective they're
not 100 effective but they're of the
most effective vaccines we've ever had
and they are almost 100 effective at
preventing severe covid which is what's
killing people
okay next it is true that vaccinated
people
may still be contagious what that means
is that the phase 3 trials on which the
vaccines were approved
didn't look at the effect of the
vaccines on transmissibility
however early data from israel suggests
that what was expected is
what is happening which is that these
vaccines pfizer and moderna
do reduce transmission again it's not
been studied
and reported in a peer-reviewed study
and we want to be careful
but the early information from israel
corroborates what was expected which is
that
we expected the vaccines would cut
transmission
hasn't been studied in the way that it
needs to be studied so
uh then we get to even if you get a
vaccine
you can't change your behavior for a
really really long time okay
let's dig into that in more detail it is
true
that just getting a shot doesn't mean
that right away you should be doing
anything differently particularly if
nobody else in your circles is
vaccinated
but once you are fully vaccinated
meaning you're seven days past your
second dose
the risk from being with other fully
vaccinated people
especially if they work from home is
very
very low and again with everyone being
vaccinated
you are reducing the risk below that of
the flu because the vaccines are so
effective at preventing severe covet
so does it make the risks zero no it
doesn't but nothing has zero risk
during flu season particularly with flu
vaccines only twenty to fifty percent
effective
uh we are accepting a certain level of
risk when we're around people during
that time
increasingly virologists and
immunologists and others are
understanding
that the vaccine is being undersold
dr muj zevik who's a virologist
said in the new york times piece our
discussion about vaccines has been poor
really poor as scientists we need to be
more careful
what we say and how it would be
understood by the public
and the focus has been uncertainty
possible bad news and it's making people
not want the vaccine
the vaccine isn't a catch-all do
whatever the hell you want
sort of get out of jail free card the
policies and grocery stores will be for
masks
for some time to come also at doctor's
offices and other lots of other places
no doubt but let's be more realistic
a small group of fully vaccinated people
who work from home
can responsibly choose to accept
the small risk of being together
and part of the problem and part of the
reason why we need
all of the fear uncertainty and doubt to
be the top line
is that so many people either don't
understand a lot of this stuff or can't
use sound judgment
so everybody has to be extra careful but
the reality is
the more people that get the vaccine
more quickly
the sooner normality or something like
it can return so
we have to stop underselling the vaccine
we have to make clear
that a lot of these catch-all umbrella
statements
are making people disinterested in the
vaccine and that's only going to prolong
the pandemic no one is advocating
irresponsible behavior some of these
headlines that are floating around are a
disaster
and they are making it so that so many
people don't want the vaccine i'll have
an example of this
later today for you uh in the voicemail
segment for the time being let's move on
to a few other things
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com
slash pacman